now let's start by getting this into
perspective right now britain has one of
if not the
strictest lockdowns in the world have a
look at this chart the higher these bars
are the tougher the restrictions on
everything from
hospitality opening to schools and this
measure from oxford university
it's a bit imprecise but it's worth
pondering as the prime minister lays out
those plans
to get that bar lower to ease lockdown
because we're coming from a high
level but that strict lockdown plus the
vaccination program might help explain
why hospital occupancy these dots here
are falling fast but where do they go
next that all depends on how fast
lockdown is
eased and say to the government
scientific group have a few scenarios to
illustrate this so scenario one if
lockdown ended pretty much
completely by the end of april you would
see
potentially hospital numbers getting up
towards 60 to 70
000. that would be the highest peak
we've seen yes it could mean a further
81
200 deaths maybe even more vaccinations
don't work as well as hopes it would
take the total death toll
to over 200 000 or scenario two
lockdown ending potentially by the end
of may imperial records that means
hospital numbers
going to slightly below the latest peak
or you've got scenario three you can see
that here that's slightly later
still in july i just say it's hard to
map the government's plans onto these
scenarios
precisely because this is based on dates
they say they're basing everything on
data but they're somewhere between
scenarios two
and three potentially and as you can see
all these later lines here
uh there's scenario four lockdown ended
by august all of them see hospital
occupancy peaking somewhere kind of
around 20 000
or below so better than last time around
and even these more optimistic parts i
should say
you still see another 33 000 deaths
according to this bring the total death
toll to 170 thousand or more and that
is if things go well and even that's
uncertain i should say modelers at
warwick did the same
exercise as imperial they found this
chart on the right here
they found that hospital numbers would
be far lower than imperial so who do we
trust out of these
two models and that's before you
consider the other uncertainty from
things like
vaccinations the impact of the seasons
and so on even the prime minister says
he wants this to be about data
we're going to check on this in the next
few weeks but remember this isn't the
only data of significance you've also
got
charts like this the impact of lockdown
on the economy
a big fall in economic output and a
financial and social toll
that's still being felt so with
infections falling
and an end to lockdown in sight the
balancing act between all of these data
points
remains incredibly tricky